I'm a being critique a critic I'm a
critique critic when I was a kid we had
taco night at my home I would eat 30
what is there not to love about tacos
drunken adventures three in the morning
20 tacos let's go
my favorite place to get tacos is
probably to pull a favorite fast-food
taco would probably be jack-in-the-box
I just love Mexican food I don't even
have to like taste it I could just like
look at it you already know that this is
gonna be the jack-in-the-box taco like
the grease on the first off this looks
like a big ravioli the meat just like
soothe your soul does that meet our
beams um is very creamy meat it's a good
in-between with a crunchy and a soft
taco yeah well I think actually just
from Justin's looks it might be from
jackin the-box because I assume the
jack-in-the-box make tacos it looks like
that I definitely think this is
jack-in-the-box I don't know I don't
even know what my options are it's from
tacos Plus this looks like high school
lunch tacos
I definitely think there's like taco
seasoning of some sort that this one has
personally not huh none of these are
Mexican I just fell apart
I this day it's like what my mom is to
me and I'm sorry mom but you're just not
getting chicken tacos this is just the
most generic like gringo taco that's
like ever gonna put together a lot of
this meat has a nicotine type quality
where I don't like it I know it's not
good for me but for some reason just one
more I think it still talk to we're
gonna say this is tacos although I think
this is from que Rico tacos Y Rico why I
[Music]
will tomato up in here well-balanced of
like all the ingredients in one bite
it's missing taco sauce yeah uncle well
yeah Papa John's taco
this one looks I didn't wait gorgeous
all night for this yes beans in it and
rice this is like a burrito yeah cut
background no cut someone put their time
into putting the saw go together
mine's falling apart and I don't care
this is delicious mmm feel like this is
Baja Fresh
cuz it's so fresh this is that Playa
loca fully or fancy Taco Bell jackin
the-box ding ding ding Joey we're
killing it to pull a they have tacos ah
what oh why didn't we oh boy it's like a
guy in a business suit and these through
people in college if you think I'm cute
while eating tacos comment below
anything I'm cute leave a like